Alright. Alright. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab podcast. And
before we get rolling on this podcast,
just a two items of business we
want to put in front of you. First,
we're going to be very, I don't
know when you're listening to this,
but if you're listening
to this before June 19th,
2013 that would be a
Wednesday next Wednesday.
Then you will find us if
you're a reddit person. Uh,
we're doing an ask me anything
for the Reddit folks on that date,
3:00 PM Eastern. So if you
want to join us there. Yeah.
And as a, as the name suggests,
you can ask us whatever you want and
we'll do our best to answer details are on
our website, radiolab.org okay.
Bit of business number two which we're
really excited about is we're very close
to announcing our next live tour, which
is going to happen later in the fall.
We're going to go to 20 cities.
It's gonna be awesome to check
radiolab.org for that too.
And now to the podcast at hand,
we are going to be considering two
very different takes on everything.
Yes. Later we'll get to physicist Brian
Green, but we're going to start with a,
a woman whose name is not Brian.
Ah, hello. Hello. Hello. Hi.
Hi. Is this Jenny buying a chance? It
sure is. Hey, my name is Jenny Hollowell.
She's a writer and author.
And here's the setup. Um,
so we were really recently asked by
the show selected shorts to curate an
evening of stories just to select
a couple for people to read. Well,
that turned out to be really hard
for us. Like we, we could not agree,
we argue to get kind of ugly internally.
I'm not going to go there. But, uh,
the one story that we all agreed on
instantly and we never really looked back
yet was the story, uh, from Jenny
Hollowell called a history of everything,
including you.
So we called her up and we asked her to
a black kind of gushed a little first.
Oh yeah. Well
there was defining there was the falling
when I know that people are gonna hear
this so they're not going to read it.
So they won't be able to dwell on just
the incredible tensions in these very
short and specific sentences
that you've written.
But I'm just wondering how long did this,
it's about a five pages
to hold in your hand.
How many decades did it take for
you to write this? Well, it's,
it's one of those stories that defies, uh,
most of my experiences
with writing stories,
which is that a kid came up
very quickly. Um, uh, and I,
I always hate hearing other writers say
how quickly something came about because
it's a rare occurrence in,
you're always kind of full of,
of envy for those moments.
This is the, you know,
one story that I think I've
ever written in a day. Wow.
But then, you know, just not
definitely take time. Okay.
Would you mind reading it
for us? Uh, and we will,
we can talk more on the
backend. Okay, sure.
A history of everything including you.
Ooh, first
there was God or gods or nothing.
[inaudible]
then synthesis space, the expanse,
explosions, implosions, particles,
objects, combustion and fusion.
[inaudible]
out of the chaos came order.
Stars were born and shown and died.
Planets rolled across their galaxies
on invisible ellipses and the elements
combined and became,
um,
life evolved or was created.
Sales trembled and divided
and gasped and found dry land.
Soon they grew legs and fins and hands
and antenna and mouths and ears and wings
and eyes, eyes that opened wide to take
all of it in the creeping, growing,
soaring, swimming, crawling,
stampeding, universe.
Eyes opened and closed and opened
again. We called it blinking
above us, shown a star
that we called the sun.
Oh,
and we call it the ground, the earth.
So we named everything, including
ourselves. We were man and woman.
And when we got lonely, we figured
out a way to make more of us.
We called it sex and
most people enjoyed it.
We fell in love. We talked about
God and Bang Stones Together,
made sparks and called them fire. We
got warmer and the food got better.
We got married, we had some children.
They cried and crawled and grew.
One, dissected flowers,
sometimes eating the pedals.
Another like to chase squirrels.
We fought wars over money and honor
and women. We starved ourselves.
We hired prostitutes, we purified
our water, we compromised,
decorated and became esoteric.
One of us stopped
breathing and turned blue
than others.
First we covered them with leaves and
then we buried them in the ground.
We remembered them, we forgot them.
We aged our buildings,
kept getting taller.
We hired lawyers and formed counsels
and left paper trials. We negotiated.
We admitted we got sick
and searched for cures.
We invented lipstick vaccines,
PyLadies solar panels, interventions,
table manners, firearms window
treatments, therapy, birth control,
tailgating, status symbols, palimony,
sportsmanship, focus groups,
Zoloft, sunscreen, landscaping,
Sesnas, fortune, cookies,
chemotherapy, convenience
foods and computers.
We angered militants and our mothers.
You were born,
you learned to walk and went to school
and played sports and lost your virginity
and got into a decent college and majored
in psychology and went to rock shows
and became political and got drunk and
changed your major to marketing and wore
turtleneck sweaters and read novels
and volunteered and went to movies and
developed a taste for
blue cheese dressing.
I met you through friends and didn't like
you. At first the feeling was mutual,
but we got used to each other.
We had sex for the first time behind
an art gallery standing up and slightly
drunk.
You held my face in your hands and said
that I was beautiful and you were too
tall with the streetlight behind you.
We went back to your place and listen
to the white album we ordered in.
We fought and made up and got good jobs.
They got married and bought an apartment
and worked out and ate more and talk
less. I got depressed. You ignored me.
I was sick of you. You drank too
much and got careless with money.
I slept with my boss.
We went into counseling and got a dog.
I bought a book of sex positions and
we tried the least degrading one.
The wheelbarrow. You took flight
lessons and subscribed to rolling stone.
I learned Spanish and started gardening.
[inaudible]
we had some children who
more or less disappointed us,
but it might have been our fault. You
were too indulgent and I was too critical.
We loved them. Anyway,
one of them died before we did
stabbed on the subway. We grieved.
We moved. We adopted a cat.
[inaudible]
the world seemed uncertain.
We live beyond our means.
I got judgmental and belligerent.
You got confused and easily tired.
You ignored me. I was
sick of you. We forgave.
Mm.
We remembered. We make
cocktails. We got tender.
There was that time on the porch
when you said, can you believe it?
[inaudible]
this was near the end and
your hands were trembling.
I think you were talking
about everything including us.
Did you want me to say it
so it would not be lost?
It was too much for me to think about.
I could not go back to the beginning.
I said, not really, and we
watched the sun go down.
A dog kept barking in the
distance and you were tired,
but you smiled and you said
here that it's rough, rough,
and we laughed. You were like that.
Now your question is my project
and our house is full of clues.
I'm reading old letters
and turning over rocks.
I bury my face in your sweaters, I
study a photograph taken at the beach,
the sun in our eyes and
the water behind us.
[inaudible]
it's a victory to remember the forgotten
picnic basket and your striped beach
blanket.
It's a victory to remember how the
jellyfish stung you and you ran screaming
from the water. It's a victory to
remember dressing the wound with meat.
Tenderizer in you
saying, I made it better.
I will tell you this.
Standing on our hill this morning, I
looked at the land we chose for ourselves.
I saw a few green patches
and our sweet little shed.
That same dog was barking.
A storm was moving in.
I did not think of heaven,
but I saw that the clouds were beautiful
and I watched them cover the sun.
[inaudible]
a history of everything,
including you or Jenny. Hello?
No,
Jenny, can you talk a
little bit about like where,
what you were thinking when you're writing
this? Like where did this come from?
Oh, well, I, the story
kind of came from that,
that impulse to kind of trace trace back.
I think maybe I was in therapy
at the time. And you know,
they always ask you about your
parents or their parents and,
and I found myself a little
frustrated by the idea that it's,
it's traceable, like whatever sort of
position you find yourself in life,
that, that you can trace
back to the origin. You know,
if you follow that logic,
then you're eventually
gonna end up in a, you know,
a protoplasm sort of situation.
And I think that's why the guys who
had, so tell me about your parents.
Tell me about their parents.
Tell you about their parents. Just
one of those kinds of things. I know,
I mean, I wait, where does it end? At
some point you're talking about, uh,
some caveman's emotionally
unavailable parents,
and to imagine one of the conversations
you might've had with your therapist,
I know you were once very religious and
then you've kind of lost your faith.
I mean, was that part of this,
does that happen near or in the
neighborhood of writing the story?
It was probably about two years
before the writing of the story,
but it was very, it was
still very fresh experience.
I was sort of in the
thick of it at the time.
And was there something of that struggle
or fall from faith that kind of got
infused into the, to the
storytelling? I think so too. I mean,
I think that definitely
is a part of, you know,
the searching that I was
going through at the time.
Just that desire to grasp
what might be the grand,
you know, a heart of it all.
So the story was a little about
that wrestling experience,
trying to explain how I'm
here, how we got here,
how we ended up in this moment.
And the logic of that is having lost a
narrative and a given to you narrative of
how things began, you were thinking, okay,
so let me see if I can work my
own narrative from the ground up.
That's, that's definitely, uh,
where I was just sort of maybe mourning
the loss of that narrative a little bit
and, and making one of
my own too, to just, uh,
give me something to,
to think about. Um, I,
I definitely don't feel like I
stumbled across any solutions,
but I felt like the,
the comfort of narrative is definitely
something I believe in. And,
and the story sort of is a extension of,
of my process about thinking
about the beginning of everything.
Well, that's creation stories go. It's
really, really nice. I have to say,
you were gonna, you know,
you're going to be hearing from Tom
Mutek rabbis and Quranic scholars,
Christian saints.
Have you ever thought about getting
a church church start winning your,
oh wow. That's a, it feels
like a, a can of worms babysit.
But thank you.
[inaudible]
that, that concludes the fonting
portion of the, uh, of the podcast.
We're going to come up
and we now have the,
the bickering portion coming up
in just a moment. Brian Greene,
professor of mathematics and Physics
at Columbia University. Baker. Baker.
Baker. Yeah. Well, we'll
continue in a second.
[inaudible]
hey, it's Nayley Miranda
from Dallas, Texas.
Radiolab is supported by Squarespace
dedicated to providing a simple way to
create websites for those
who are growing a business,
starting a blog or
opening an online store.
Squarespace provides templates and
tools to create professional websites.
Users create sites that are mobile
ready, which include 24 seven support,
a domain name and e-commerce all on
the same platform for a free trial,
visit squarespace.com/radiolab.
Hi, this is Josh Goldstein
calling from bend, Oregon.
Radiolab is supported by undercurrent
I consulting firm in Lower Manhattan.
Thinking about bitcoins, holacracy
and Berger making robots.
More thoughts on how complex
organizations thrive in the digital
age@undercurrent.com
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we're back. Uh, we just heard a
story by Jenny Hollowell called a,
a brief history of everything,
including you. Five pages,
kind of encompassing the
entire universe, everything.
Can we do this in a completely
different way? Yeah, part two. Okay,
so this is about what do for a living.
You know that I have this neighbor
and friend, Brian Greene, Brian Green,
professor of physics and mathematics.
Columbia University. Yes, I do know that.
And the thing about Brian is he
is a theoretical physicist. Now,
theoretical physicists say that it's
theoretically possible to know everything
there is to know in the universe.
So one day they'll be able to explain
not only how you could send a rocket to
the moon,
but the laws that govern space
and energy and time and gravity,
every thing,
the whole universe one day they think
might be totally understandable using
logic and mathematical equations.
Now you can't take that too far.
And none of us really imagined
that if you asked the equations,
what are we going to have
for dinner tomorrow night,
the equations will spit out
fried Tofu and you know,
spring rolls or something like that.
But at the level of the
fundamental ingredients,
the particles that make up the
universe, their properties,
the hope and the goal is that the
theories that we work out will apply
everywhere and tell us about everything
you just said. Everything yes.
As in everything. Yes.
That's the big, big goal.
This is like playing
poker. You're helping me.
I don't know what you're gonna do. All
right. We'll take it to the next step.
Okay. Wait, so what do you, what
are you up to here? Krulwich
well, we, you know, we argue, oh,
that's the fun thing we do, but sure.
But unlike him,
my position has always been that it's
going to be very hard to answer all the
puzzles in the universe. And frankly,
it's not a bad thing if some mysteries
remain mysterious. Yeah, that's my view.
But because is so smart when I tell
them, how do you know whenever he,
he always wins the arguments,
but a few months ago, this is,
this is the thing that got
this whole thing started.
I was reading Harper's magazine and
I found an article written by another
physicist and a novelist, Alan
Lightman. I thought, oh boy,
this is going to drive Brian Bats because
everyone says theirs is a group of
physicists and Brian happens to be one
of them who've embraced a very exciting
idea with an unfortunate effect. If
this idea, it turns out to be true,
Allen writes, it will then be impossible
for physicist to know everything,
which I thought, ah,
excellent. What is the art?
What is the idea it has to do
with with more than one universe,
you know there is a very weak, you
know this, we talked about it before,
that there is a a a vogue now for
the idea that instead of one universe
encompassing everything, there
might be more than one, right?
So there actually are a number of ways
that physics comes upon this idea of
other universes.
Maybe the most intuitive is
to think about the big bang,
that sense space rushing outward and
matter could cool on yield to stars and
galaxies.
That wonderful picture that we've had
with us since the 1920s we have in the
interim interim decades come to the
possibility that the big bang may not be a
onetime event. That is there.
It may have been many big bangs and may
continue to be big bang, like events,
each spawning its own universe.
If that were the case,
then our universe would then be viewed
as one of many in this grand collection
emerging from all of these
big bang like events.
Now in this few of things,
there could be not just one universe
or three or 19 there could be 10,000 it
could be, it could be trillions.
That could be an infinite number.
And here's the crucial thing.
Each and every one of these universes
can be different from its neighbor.
Vastly different. That's right.
So when we studied the equations for
the production of these universes,
we see in the mathematics that the
other universes could have different
features, different particle compositions,
different masses of the particles,
different forces. Some
of them might have Adam,
some of them might not have that up. You
could have universities, lots of stars,
some with no stars, some could be
made of Munster cheese. I don't know.
The fundamental properties of each
universe could be very different.
That's exactly right. And that's the
key to Ellen Lachman's argument. Well,
then going back to the
beginning of our conversation,
if a physicist job is to explore
everything that is the universe now the
universe has just been
demoted to a sub universe.
Then when you get your diploma
from a great university,
the president of the
university is my friends.
We are gathered here to meet the people
who have earned the credentials to
describe the sub universe a
little bit of what we could know.
It's like you've been demoted.
You thought that you were going to get
to learn about everything, your word,
and now I didn't have that. Your
everything is very, it's sub. Oh,
I wouldn't describe it like that
at all. As you might imagine,
rather than do you this as an
incredible loss of understanding.
The right way of viewing it,
I think is to recognize that certain
questions that we were asking when we
thought there was just one
universe where the wrong questions,
meaning meaning what well piece has.
Here's the way to think about it.
This is how it always go. As we've seen
this before in the history of science
[inaudible]
take Kepler Yohanas Kepler
was an astronomer and a
kind of mapper of the solar
system.
He was trying to figure out where the
planets were and the nature of their
orbits and stuff and Kepler spent a long
time trying to find an explanation for
why the earth is 93 million
miles away from the sun.
93 million kept with of the has
to be a really important number,
a key to a deeper mystery,
but we now know that he was
barking up the wrong tree.
Why there isn't just one planet.
There are many planets. In fact,
many planets around many stars and the
distances of those planets from their
hosts are varies over a wide range
of possibilities. Mars, for example,
is 141 million miles
from the sun, Jupiter,
483 million and when you start comparing
the different distances of planets from
the sun, you realize that the fact that
the earth is 93 million miles away,
it doesn't seem like a deep
law of the universe anymore.
It just feels kind of arbitrary.
And then that forces you to change
the question. Not why 93 million. No,
why all these different planets at
different distances from the sun.
And yet they all stick around the sun.
They're all trapped in the neighborhood.
That question puts you on
the road to a deeper thought.
The theory of gravity. The point is says
Brian, if you're focused on one thing,
you're going to think that one
thing is the key to everything.
When you're one turns to
many, then you think, ah,
well the one thing that really wasn't
so special buck, the way Brian sees it,
that is progress. That is understanding.
And then it frees you up to ask other
kinds of questions such as what's the law
of gravity? What is the equation that
allows us to understand how the sun form.
So those are real questions and when
you can toss out the ones that are red
herrings that you thought were deep,
but they're actually just
asking the wrong question,
that frees you up to make progress.
And Brian says you can make the exact
same kind of progress if you compare
universes.
So instead of asking why is our one
universe the way it is now you can ask,
well,
what do all of these universes so
different one from the other still have in
common.
That would be pretty heavy and exciting
to describe the underlying laws that
govern all universes regardless of their
detailed features and what it would be
like in that universe or that universe
or that universe. Way over there.
There are infinite number of them.
So if I told you that you could write
anything down and it might be a universe,
black universe is white, universe is
green, universe is soft university,
Harvard University, muscular
universities, teenie universities,
urged universities, then the only one
you know intimately is your own. Um,
it seems to me that, what do you
know about those other units?
Other than that they might be very
different and then we don't know very much
observationally. Sure. We can't see them.
We don't know very much experimentally.
So they're definitely on a very
different footing from that perspective.
But Bryan believes that one day we might
be able to experimentally detect these
other universes and somehow it'll kind
of pick up their distant vibrations.
Kind of like the way you
hear your neighbors music,
it's just emanating through the
walls. We might be able to listen in,
he says and take a couple of measurements,
which would be quite wonderful.
And in that case at least there's a chance
that we can observational evidence of
the existence of these other realms.
And at that point I would begin to say,
hmm, maybe there's something
really to this. So the physics
doing says I can't go
there. I can't observe it.
At least for the moment.
All I have is my brain and my
math and I say from my brain,
I'm going to just assume
certain things are always true.
There's always going to be gravity to
say there's always going to be some
particle or wave that creates matter.
There's always going to
be a w, W I don't know.
What else are there things that
they're always going to be?
What are they that are
always going [inaudible]
the the things that you were describing
need not always really case. Yes.
What would be the cases that the
fundamental governing equations,
the mathematical laws would be the
underlying architecture that governs what
happens in those places. But
environmental details can change things.
Absolutely. Really
dramatic mental details.
That's actually something you know at
some level right now, right on the moon,
you could jump a lot
higher than you can here.
So if you didn't get to two,
bodies do attract each other.
That's right.
So there is a fundamental law of gravity
that manifests itself in different ways
based on the environment. All right, so
let me say that again or ask it again.
Are there fundamental laws yes.
That you think operate in all? Yes.
Yes, absolutely.
And why do you think that that is a
starting point when we come upon this
possibility of other universes?
It's not a crazy idea that we dream up
late at night when there's nothing else
to think about.
These are ideas that emerge from the
fundamental equations that we use to
describe the things that we
do see in the world around us,
and we follow the equations
and the equations suggest
to us there might be these
other universes, so we have equations,
we analyze them and we interpret what
they're telling us about reality,
but those are the very equations that
come to this possibility of other
universes. Then those are the equations
that govern those other universes.
The starting point is let's assume
that these are the fundamental awful,
why is God three in one or why did,
why does the, was the
world made in seven days?
I T it aren't we getting
close to some sort of a,
you're believing in certain things to
be always true the way religious people
believe. Certain things are always true,
not because you've seen it
or it just because you can't.
You have a faith in it.
I couldn't disagree with
you more. I thought, Nah,
it has absolutely
nothing to do with faith.
The reason why we trust the equations
is because we've got century's worth of
observational and experimental evidence
that the equations take us in the right
direction here, here,
and it's those very same equations that
work here that we are following to their
logical conclusion to see where
the mathematics takes us. Right?
So if you remember the the train of
reasoning, he may have just projected
here into there. That's faith talking. No,
you can't go there. All
you can do is say, well,
what works with my deep understanding
of here has to be there.
I don't know why it has to be,
but that's what you just said.
No, it's actually the reasoning goes
to somewhat reverse order. From that,
we build mathematical
equations to describe here.
We then follow those equations
and say, Oh my goodness.
Those equations that we developed to
describe here are telling us that there is
something over there.
And then we're like, wow,
the equation to a great job of describing
things here and the equations have
this feature that they tell us.
There's another place over there.
Maybe that's possible.
The key thing on logic
in your mind. Oh, this is,
this is not belief [inaudible].
This is just logic.
Aren't you worried though that there's
another Brian Green in university number
three thousand seven hundred and ninety
million two hundred and eight 600 and
thousand 40 and five who is sitting here
talking to another radio reporter in
another university? Anything? Well,
we know all about the other universities
because we're assuming that the math
here is the same as the math
there in that other place,
but as it turns out, they're
math and aren't the same,
so they will not they that is
that. You may just be wrong. Oh,
that's always the possible. In fact,
it's likely the possibility. In fact,
99.99% of everything we do is wrong.
Not from the point of
view we make a mistake,
but is Reuters is a deep wrong is that
you somehow are or somehow feeling that
the math is a clue that
everything follows your math.
If at some point the maths collide
and then the universe is collide,
then that would be very
unsettling to both of you.
I would assume in terms of whether
the math is him, I'll contradictory
[inaudible] your tools of
learning are not working.
That would suggest that we were both wrong
and that there's a deeper overarching
framework. I mean, I, I
hate to use the word faith,
but the one point where
I'll give you faith is this.
I do have a deep faith that the universe
is coherent and by universe call it
multiverse, whatever word you
want to use, the whole thing.
I do believe that it's coherent. Now,
whether that means it follows
mathematical laws. I don't know.
It could be the case that, you know,
when we talked to those aliens that we
encounter one day and they say, okay,
show us what you got.
We bring out our equations and they
kind of laugh at us and say, Oh,
you guys are still stuck on math, you
know? And they said, yeah, you know,
1,010 thousand years ago
we were doing math too.
But here's the real way of describing
it. Now what they be showing us,
what the real way of
describing it. I have no idea.
I can't even imagine what it would
be that would be non mathematical.
So I do have a deep
faith that it's coherent.
And the only tool that I
know how to encapsulate that
coherence are mathematical
equations. So if Zan tar,
Brian and Brian here come
up with equations that Cole
allied with another and
don't
work,
to me it just means that both were wrong
and there's some bigger overarching
coherence that we've
yet to find. That's it.
[inaudible]
I don't even, I can't even begin
to figure out if you did you just,
when did you lose? I
can't tell what, wait.
So this whole came from Alan
lightens article. Right?
So do you think he beat the objections
in the article? Did he beat the article?
Well, I thought it would be fair to
ask the author of the article. So I,
I called Allen. Yup. What happened is it
turns out to be in non Penn, Cambodia.
I, I make all my international calls on
and I, I sent him the interview
with Brian. He listened
good. I listened to,
and I asked, well, what do you
think about Brian's uh, argument?
Well, I, I don't think that he's wrong,
but I think that the problem
is philosophically more
disturbing than what he is
confessing.
He said, well,
I think it's going to be much harder
than Brian things to actually sense or
encounter or measure these other
universe if they exist at all.
We don't even know whether the outer
universe is exist in the same space and
time that we do.
And there are other physicists who
feel that the universes are even in
principle, never, never observable by us,
that we will never be able to have any
physical evidence of their existence.
And that possibility is
what I find disturbing.
[inaudible]
it may be that this is the way nature is.
What does that mean?
Well, I mean it may be that,
that we've done as much
explaining as as possible
[inaudible]
and that we will never ever
really understand everything.
Yes. And others we may be,
we may have pushed the human mind
if as far as it can possibly go.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
so, uh, is that everything I
think we can say about everything.
I think that's everything. All
right. Okay. Oh, we should go over.
Thank Brian Green professor of physics
and math at Columbia University.
Alan Lightman up at MIT who's essay, uh,
the accidental universe will appear in
a book of the same name coming out this
fall. So if you want to read the essay,
either you buy it in book form soon.
Thanks also to Jenny
Hollowell of course. Uh,
will link you to her short story from
our website, radiolab.org and meantime,
we'll just say goodbye. Bye Bye.